deux invités à présent sur ce plateau
annick thomas c'est bon soir bénévoles
artisans du monde et patrick théron
bonsoir vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration d'artisans du monde à
saint quentin en yvelines on va parler
de la quinzaine du commerce équitable
qui débute le 4 mai le commerce
équitable
on voit souvent cette mention presque un
peu partout et n'importe comment est-ce
qu'on peut peut-être pour commencer
redéfinir ce qu'est le commerce
équitable commerce équitable c'est un
partenariat essentiellement le boulot
point de départ c'est que c'est un
partenariat entre le producteur et les
personnes qui lui achète il peut y avoir
plus ou moins d'intermédiaires mais
partenariat dans lequel l'acheteur
s'engage à payer un prix juste
c'est à dire un prix qui est fixée en
accord avec le producteur l'action
d'artisans du monde il ya trois axes
pour définir cette action faire
respecter les droits économiques sociaux
culturels environnementaux des peuples
modifier les règles du commerce
international et puis préserver les
principes d'un commerce équitable
exigeant et politique ça veut dire quoi
à commercer équitable exigeant et
politiques alors exigeant c'est à dire
que artisans du monde souhaite que
l'ensemble de la filière soit équitable
non seulement que le prix payé aux
producteurs soient justes mais que
l'ensemble des structures qui
interviennent jusqu'à l'acheteur
jusqu'au consommateur
nous lisons consom'acteurs est bien là
aussi soit puisse être transparente
c'est à dire qu'on sache exactement dans
la filière comment sont répartis les
bénéfices il faut des bénéfices tout le
temps on doit vivre mais on souhaite
qu'il soit il est exigeant parce qu'on
souhaite
on a un niveau de transparence qui est
très fort et il est politique parce que
nous souhaitons effectivement que
c'est ce qu'on préconise dans la
campagne beyond 2015 au delà 2015 les
règles du commerce international soit
modifié parce que nous pensons qu'elles
sont à l'origine de nombreuses
inégalités et du fait que la pauvreté ne
régresse pas comme peut-être il faut
comme elle devrait régresser
compte tenu de la quantité de richesse
qui est produite mondialement qui est
énorme
commerce équitable cette année pour la
quinzaine est présentée comme une
alternative face à la crise on va parler
billion de 2015 parce que je sais que
aussi ça vous tient à coeur il ya une
déclaration qui circulent auprès des
élus locaux on va l'évoquer mais juste
comment on peut faire du commerce
équitable une alternative face à la
crise le commerce équitable en
permettant que tous les acteurs du
circuit économique soit à égalité en
partenariat permet à chacun de vivre
dignement du fruit de son travail
c'est une répartition différente de la
richesse alors il ya le made in france
et vous répondez le médine monde
c'est une jolie formule ça signifie quoi
c'est une question de solidarité
nous pensons que face à la crise
personne ne peut agir individuellement
nous pensons que effectivement il y à
une question de solidarité et que c'est
cette solidarité mise en action par des
partenariats qui peut aider à combattre
la crise la crise au départ elle est
quand même financière et donc
nous pensons que retour à mener à la
finance est une mauvaise chose que le
commerce doit exister mais qui doit
exister d'une façon juste et donc il est
illusoire de penser qu'un pays va
s'isoler totalement mais que du nord au
sud les filières doivent être équitables
et doivent être justes et donc chacun
comme ça pourra effectivement vivre
convenablement
nous disons que le prix que payent les
uns au départ c'est le revenu des autres
si le prix est trop bas ils revenus ne
peuvent pas être convenable voilà quoi
ça me disait un billion de 2015
justement le commerce équitable au coeur
des objectifs du millénaire pour le
développement c'est l'intitulé d'une
déclaration qui circulent actuellement
auprès des différents élus locaux à
travers la france
pourquoi cette pétition et pour qui en
l'an 2000 l'onu a fait une déclaration
les objectifs du millénaire pour le
développement avec l'a8 objectifs à
poursuivre et à atteindre pour 2015 et
donc il y a une clause de revoyure en
septembre 2013
autour de ces huit objectifs pour
définir de nouvelles
de nouveaux objectifs au delà de 2015
sachant que malheureusement les
objectifs de landes de fixés en l'an
2000 n'ont pas été tous atteints et donc
c'est au pic de se fixer de nouveaux
objectifs
c'est le premier ont pas été atteints
non ce qu'il s'est fixé des objectifs
c'est vrai ça veut dire qu'ils étaient
peut-être trop ambitieux ou mal posée
donc l'objet de de ce collectif millions
de 2015 c'est de peser sur les débats
qui sont en cours pour définir de
nouveaux objectifs et de nouveaux moyens
de les atteindre et la déclaration
actuellement qui circulent pour cette
signature ces signatures d élus pour
l'instant les élus vous ont répondu
alors un certain nombre l'ont signé
d'autres nous ont répondu qu'ils allait
la signer
donc moi dans cette déclaration comment
on trouve quoi dans cette déclaration ce
à quoi il s'engage voilà alors c'est une
demande qu'ils font que va porter dire
que toutes ces déclarations seront
portés par le représentant de la france
à l'onu
et donc ce qu'elle demande c'est que
dans les objectifs de beyond donc d'au
delà 2015 il soit tenu compte des
réformes structurelles qui peuvent être
mis en place pour éradiquer la pauvreté
et que les partenariats tels que entre
les collectivités c'est pour ça qu'on
s'adresse aux élus locaux entre les
collectivités les producteurs tels que
le commerce équitable et commerce
équitable c'est pas lui a tout d'une
seule qui va éradiquer la pauvreté on
est bien d'accord mais que ce soit dit
que c'est un des outils qui peuvent
permettre d'y arriver
justement pas souvent de boîte à outils
en ce moment c'est un bon outil on parle
de l'engagement des élus juste pour
conclure votre engagement à vous il a
commencé qu'en 2005
et pourquoi je me suis toujours
intéressé au cas l'économie et je pense
que le commerce et le cab est quelque
chose qui peut lui donner une autre
structure un autre cadre voilà une plus
humain défense des droits humains et
votre engagement à vous
2004-2005 causé par les mêmes raisons la
même raison le c'est un moyen avec de
réfléchir à ses actes de consommation à
se remettre en cause et à voir que les
histoires comporte quotidiennement dans
notre vie quotidienne ont une histoire
la quinzaine du commerce équitable qui
débute le 4 mai puis cette déclaration à
faire signe à vos élus pour qu'ils
s'engagent on la retrouve aussi sur le
site d'artisans du monde artisans du
monde point org merci à vous